y la reconstrucción mamaria ayuda a
restaurar la apariencia de la mama
después de una mastectomía se puede
llevar a cabo al momento de realizar la
mastectomía o con posterioridad usted y
su cirujano seleccionará en el tipo de
cirugía reconstructiva que mejor le
convenga generalmente sus opciones
incluirán un implante sintético o uno de
dos procedimientos que utilizan su
propio tejido para reconstruir su mama
un colgajo músculo cutáneo el dorsal
ancho o un colgajo mío cutáneo
transverso del recto abdominal conocido
también como colgajo trump antes del
procedimiento se le colocará una vía
endovenosa y es posible que se le
suministre un sedante por vía oral para
ayudarle a relajarse las
reconstrucciones mamarias se realizan
con anestesia general durante el tiempo
que dure la cirugía usted estará dormida
y se le insertará un tubo respiratorio
por la boca y la garganta para ayudarla
a respirar durante la operación
para un colgajo músculo cutáneo del
dorsal ancho el cirujano realizará una
incisión en la parte superior de la
espalda separar a una sección de tejido
y girará el colgajo hasta posicionarlo
en la zona de la mastectomía
y un colgajo mío cutáneo transverso del
recto abdominal o colgajo trump comienza
cuando el cirujano realiza una incisión
en la piel del tórax luego el cirujano
realizará una incisión elíptica en la
piel la grasa y el músculo de la pared
abdominal o de no haber suficiente
tejido en el abdomen en la parte
inferior de la espalda a continuación el
cirujano deslizará el tejido debajo de
la piel hasta la zona de la mastectomía
para formar un montículo mamario se
tendrá mucho cuidado de conservar el
suministro de sangre hacia el montículo
reconstruido
finalmente el cirujano suturar a la
herida original de la espalda o abdomen
el procedimiento para los colgajos de
tejido es similar independientemente de
que se realice de inmediato o un tiempo
después de la mastectomía sin embargo el
procedimiento para los implantes
sintéticos depende del momento en que se
realice la reconstrucción si decide
realizarse el implante al momento de
someterse a la mastectomía el cirujano
le insertará inmediatamente después de
extirpar el tejido de la mama y cerrará
la herida con suturas si elige
realizarse el implante con posterioridad
es posible que la piel necesite
estirarse antes de que se produzca la
reconstrucción en este caso el cirujano
volverá a abrir la incisión en el lugar
de la mastectomía e insertar a un
expansor de tejidos con forma de globo
durante algunas semanas el cirujano
logrará que la pared torácica y la piel
se estiren al inyectar regularmente
solución salina en el expansor de
tejidos
en una segunda operación el cirujano
realizará otra incisión extraerá el
expansor de tejidos insertará un
implante sintético y cerrará la herida
con suturas
después de la cirugía se retirará el
tubo respiratorio y se trasladará al
área de recuperación posquirúrgica para
su monitoreo generalmente las
reconstrucciones mamarias son
procedimientos hospitalarios y la
mayoría de las pacientes permanecen en
el hospital de 1 a 5 días después de la
cirugía
una vez completado el montículo mamario
puede decidir que le reconstruyan el
pezón y la areola este es un
procedimiento relativamente fácil y por
lo general se puede realizar en el
consultorio del médico ya que dura de 30
a 60 minutos existen diferentes tipos de
reconstrucciones del pezón la más común
consiste en extraer tejido del muslo
interno y oreja para crear un montículo
pequeño parecido a un pezón que se puede
tatuar para parecerse más a un pezón y
areola natural es este pezón de
reemplazo se fija al área central de la
mama reconstruida